>> Laura: TIME NOW FOR
DEFENDING THE FIRST SERIES WHERE
WE EXPOSE THE ENEMIES OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT, FREE
EXPRESSION, AND FREE THOUGHT.
THE MEDIA RESEARCH CENTER
RELEASED THIS DEVASTATING REPORT
TODAY DOCUMENTING THE CENSORSHIP
OF CONSERVATIVE SPEECH BY
SILICON VALLEY'S TOLERANT TECH
GIANTS.
AMONG THE FINDINGS, CLAIMS FROM
FORMER EMPLOYEES THAT FACEBOOK
HIDE CONSERVATIVE CONTENT FROM
THE TRENDING SECTION, BACKED UP
BY A DETAILED STUDY.
YOUTUBE, GOOGLE, AND TWITTER
PARTNERED WITH LEFTIST GROUPS
THAT HIT CONSERVATIVES AND CHECK
THIS OUT.
OF THE 25 MEMBERS ON THE PANEL
THAT GUIDES TWITTER'S POLICIES,
12 ARE LIBERALS AND ONLY ONE IS
CURRENT ON MY CONSERVATIVE.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THERE IS ONE.
SHOCKING BUT NOT SURPRISING, IS
THAT?
FOR MORE DETAILS, WE ARE JOINED
BY THE FOUNDER OF THE VERY
IMPORTANT AND INDISPENSABLE
MEDIA CENTER.
IT IS GREAT TO HAVE YOU.
FIRST APPEARANCE OF MARSHALL,
MAN!
WHERE HAVE YOU BEEN?
TELL US WHAT YOU FOUND.
>> IS A MASSIVE STUDY DONE BY
MY COLLEAGUES.
50 PAGES DOCUMENTING WHAT
CONSERVATIVES HAVE BEEN
SUGGESTING HAS BEEN HAPPENING.
THIS IS -- IT SOUNDS HYPERBOLIC,
BUT LAURA, THIS IS TRUE.
THIS IS EMERGING, THE GREATEST
CENSORSHIP OF FREE SPEECH
WORLDWIDE IN THE HISTORY OF MAN.
LET ME EXPLAIN THIS.
THE LEFT IS ON G HOT AGAINST
CONSERVATIVE THOUGHT.
IT'S HAPPENING IN ACADEMIA,
ENTERTAINMENT, BUSINESS,
RELIGION, EVERYWHERE.
EVERYWHERE, THEY ARE SUPPRESSING
CONSERVATIVE THOUGHT.
NOW THEY ARE GOING TO THE SOCIAL
MEDIA GIANTS.
THESE SOCIAL MEDIA GIANTS HAVE
AUDIENCES OF THE BILLIONS.
WOULD WE HAVE SHOWN IN THIS
MASSIVE REPORT IS WHETHER IT IS
FACEBOOK, TWITTER, GOOGLE,
YOUTUBE, THEY ARE ALL EMPLOYING
DIFFERENT TACTICS TO GO AGAINST
CONSERVATIVES.
>> Laura: WAS GOING THROUGH
SOME OF THESE.
CENSORSHIP OF CONSERVATIVE
SPEECH.
HERE'S AN EXAMPLE.
GOOGLE'S SEARCH SHOWED THAT THE
2016 CAMPAIGN SEARCHES WERE
BIASED IN FAVOR OF
HILLARY CLINTON.
YOUTUBE SHUTTING DOWN
CONSERVATIVE CHANNELS BY
MISTAKE, BY REMOVING VIDEOS THAT
PROMOTE WHITE       RIGHT WING O
PROMOTE WHITE       RIGHT WING I
PROMOTE WHITE       RIGHT WING A
PROMOTE WHITE       RIGHT WING L
VIEWS.
THEY RELY ON LEFT-WING
FACT-CHECKERS LIKE SNOPES AND
WIKIPEDIA.
WHY IS WIKIPEDIA LEFT-WING?
>> THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS THAT
WIKIPEDIA DOES, IT WAS A LIBERAL
SPIN.
>> Laura: WE ALWAYS HAVE TO
EDIT MY PAGE, I KNOW THAT.
I STOPPED LOOKING.
>> THEY INSERT, INSERT NASTY
STUFF ABOUT YOU.
THEY HAVE BEEN, THEY HAVE BEEN
IMPORTUNED
PARTNERING WITH THEM TO UNMASK
CONSERVATIVES AND TO GO AGAINST
CONSERVATIVE CONTENT AND TO
UNCOVER THESE AWFUL
CONSERVATIVES AND WHAT THEY ARE
DOING.
>> Laura: YOU SAY THAT WAR IS
BEING DECLARED ON THE
CONSERVATIVE MOVEMENT AND
CONSERVATIVES ARE LOSING BADLY.
IF THE RIGHT IS SILENT, BILLIONS
OF PEOPLE WILL BE CUT OFF FROM
CONSERVATIVES IDEALS.
THAT IS REALLY TRUE, ISN'T IT?
EVEN THOUGH THE SOVIETS
SUPPRESSED SPEECH, TRYING TO
SUPPRESS HIS SPEECH, WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT IN EFFECT A GLOBAL
EFFORT TO SUPPRESS OUR
SILENCE CONSERVATIVES.
WE HAVE SEEN THE NONSENSE
HAPPENING TO SHOWS LIKE MINE,
THEY TRY TO DO IT WITH BRUSH AND
OTHERS.
THIS IS WHAT THEY DO PRAY THEY
DON'T WANT TO DEBATE BECAUSE
THEY ARE LOSING ON THE
SUBSTANCE.
ARE THEY NOT?
THEY WANT TO SILENCE.
WITH THE POWER OF HIGH TECH,
WHAT CAN WE COME WITH THE
CONSUMERS OF INFORMATION AND
OTHERS WATCHING, WHAT CAN THEY
DO?
>> THEY HAVE TO RECOGNIZE WHAT
IS GOING ON.
JACK DORSEY IS THE CEO OF
TWITTER.
HE JUST RECENTLY, HE WAS
PROMOTED -- HE PROMOTED AN
ARTICLE THAT CALLS FOR THE
DESTRUCTIVE OF THE CONSERVATIVE
MOVEMENT.
>> Laura: HE RETWEETED IT.
IF THAT JUST --
>> IT'S NOT JUST HAPPENING IN
THE UNITED STATES.
CONSERVATIVES HAVE TO RECOGNIZE
THIS AND START LOOKING FOR NEW
HOMES.
>> Laura: OUR OWN PLATFORM?
>> CONSERVATIVES, IF THEY LEAVE,
THE BUSINESS MODEL FALLS.
CONGRATULATIONS THAT YOUR
AUDIENCE IS UP 20% EVER SINCE
THEY WENT AFTER YOU.
>> Laura: GLASS HALF-FULL HERE
ON "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
BRENT, THANK YOU, WE WILL LINK
THIS ON MY FACEBOOK PAGE.